الداخل الروسي لم يعد بعيدا عن تداعيات
الحرب الجاريه في اوكرانيا حتى القواعد
العسكريه الروسيه لم تعد بعيده عن استهداف
الاوكرانيين الذين غيروا في الاونه
الاخيره من مسار المعارك على الارض مسؤول
اوكراني اكد ان كيف استهدفت قاعدتين
روسيتين جويتين تبعدني مئات الاميال عن
الحدود الاوكرانيه باستخدام طائرات بدون
طيار المسيرات اطلقت من داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه واستهدفت القاعدتين العسكريتين
بمساعده قوات خاصه قريبه من المكان
استهدافه القاعدتين اعتبرته صحيفه تايمز
جزءا من خطه عسكريه اوسع تتضمن استعدادا
كيف لنقل القتال الى اهداف عسكريه في قلب
روسيا
مسيرات اوكرانيا استهدفت قاعده انجلز
الجويه الروسيه بالقرب من سيراتوف جنوبي
موسكو والتي تقعده مئات الاميال عن الحدود
الاوكرانيه وقاعده دياجولي العسكريه وسط
مقاطعه ريزان على بعد حوالي 150 كيلومترا
من موسكو موسكو رات ان الهجوم هدفه تدمير
اسطول القاذفات الاستراتيجيه للحد من
الهجمات الروسيه التي اشتدت على مدار
الاسابيع الاخيره وبعد ساعات شهدت منطقه
كورس الروسيه المحاذيه لاوكرانيا هجوما
اخر بطائرات مسيره ادى الى اندلاع النيران
في خزان النفط جاسم محسن العربيه